dans l'actualité également ce soir ils
sont partis les gens du voyage installés
depuis mardi sur la plaine de la
gloriette pour leur grand rassemblement
évangélique ils ont quitté les lieux cet
après midi mardi dernier leur arrivée ne
s'était pas faite en toute discrétion le
sud de la ville avait été entièrement
bloqués tout comme le tram jusqu'à ce
que l'entrée sur la plaine de la
gloriette lensois autorisé il avait été
pourtant dirigé au préalable vers l'être
vers l'ère de grand passage de tours
mais il avait considéré trop petit alors
quelles sont les obligations pour les
communes en matière d'accueil des gens
du voyage on voit c'est avec aurélie
renault et guillaume blot durant une
semaine la plaine de la gloriette était
comble 180 caravanes soit plus de 600
personnes rassemblées pour la pentecôte
la communauté a refusé de s'installer
sur l'air de grand passage du pont aux
oies situé à quelques centaines de
mètres une aire dédiée à accueillir les
grands rassemblements ouverte l'été
dernier la première de ce type en
indre-et-loire voulais pas me lucie pour
fuir la loi ont réussi pour dresser le
chapiteau et puis rester huit jours et
annoncer l'évangile sur la de grand
passage qu'ils ont fait c'est pas
possible de mettre ses troupes qu'il n'y
a pas assez pas assez grand si la loi du
5 juillet 2000 prévoit l'installation
d'aires permanente pour les communes de
plus de 5000 habitants
les aires de grand passage elles sont
une préconisation elles peuvent
permettre d'accueillir des
rassemblements entre 50 et 200 caravanes
celle de tours et jauger à 150
le tout sur un terrain de 3 ha
représentant 3 128 mille euros
d'investissement auxquels s'ajoutent dix
mille euros de frais mensuels
d'entretien une infrastructure
suffisante pour le maire de tours donc
l'aménagement correspond aux exigences
de la loi
les tourangeaux ont payé d'une façon
très large
cette installation on n'ira pas plus
loin imaginons qu'on agrandisse l'air de
grand passage
actuellement existantes pour l'amener à
180 ce qui correspondrait à la demande
de cette année six à la pentecôte de
l'année prochaine et je peux prendre le
pari arrive un groupe de 200 caravanes
la plaisanterie va recommencer
depuis sa création en juillet dernier et
lé aire de grand passage aurait
accueilli moins de dix rassemblement
hier une nouvelle communauté s'y est
installée pour la centaine de caravanes
un problème de taille l'électricité donc
faudra qu'ils peu plus de puissance
parce que les deux boîtiers son ensemble
donc seront en branchant caravane celui
de boîtiers de les boîtiers vont au
front ça va pas ça va pas le faire pour
pallier ce problème sur l'air de grand
passage
la communauté a trouvé une solution
périlleuse des centaines de mètres de
câbles pour atteindre les équipements
d'une aire d'accueil permanentes voisine
celle qui appartient à la ville de joué
les tours